the valerant community has been sounding
the alarm for North American VCT
America's teams after two tier 2 teams
dumpstered partner teams in the recent
lwig trick Invitational so are tier 2
teams better than tier one teams and
should we be worried for the upcoming
VCT America
season it has been a long time since
I've been on here covering Val e sports
but you also know the Jal anyways hit
that like button that subscribe button
and ring that notification Bell for me
thank you in case you missed it the
second ever lwig T Invitational was held
over the weekend and we had two tier 2
teams mxs and oxygen in the grand finals
with oxygen coming out on top here they
are the Champs are out the Champs the
Champs the Champs here's the
trophy gentlemen congratulations some
grab it I didn't
win there we go now this tournament is
where I'm sure a bunch of you met
absolute stars like Redux and Verno for
the very first time Dash
in
goodness sh oh my God kill this is also
the tournament that saw two tier one
teams Cloud9 and 100 thieves be defeated
by tier 2 teams and do you know what
that means that's right folks it's time
to play we pretend it's doomsday for the
losing teams by taking these results too
seriously let's take a look at our
contestants already we have the cryos
cell's bad Squad firing very strong
working in tanzen with the buo is a
fraud group but watch out it's the C9
suck stable hitting their finisher look
at Randy Orton slithering watch out
watch out watch I've been gone for
months I had to get like one wrestling
reference in here what did you expect
all jokes aside many fans and just plain
viewers alike have come to pretty
damning conclusions about certain teams
based on an Invitational with four teams
and no points at stake an Invitational
in the off season and Invitational as
the title was suggest a tournament that
teams were simply invited to compete in
and did not earn a spot in I understand
the worry but how seriously as a fan
base should we be taking these
tournaments if tier one is losing
handedly to tier 2 is North America in
trouble for their performance and are we
holding back the best of the best
because of the partner program I asked
people on both VR and R valerant
competitive about how much stock they
put into tournaments like these and
pretty much the entire sentiment from
everyone was take it with a giant grain
of salt one reply to my post on blr said
for me offseason events are like scrims
but on steroids teams are testing strats
trying to build Synergy I usually don't
care about offseason Tournament results
and while that may be the general
sentiment of people who replied to me
there are still a bunch of people who
consider these results as a sign of the
times but are both sides missing a
bigger Point blood W seems to think so
wait why are these tier one teams not
looking very tier one true because tier
one's an arbitrary metric based off the
teams that Riot invited to be a part of
the league it's nothing to do with the
level of skill you're such a shill bro
am I a shill am I a shill speaking facts
Beyond how arbitrary tiers as a
measurement are the valer community has
constructed this idea that tier 2 is
worse than tier one that the reason
players are in tier 2 is because they
are not as good tier one are just
organizations Riot invited to be a part
of the partner program there is no
further requirement for their staff or
players to be at a certain level and you
might be thinking well since they were
invited shouldn't they be attracting the
best of the best talent wise how can
tier one not be better than tier 2 well
there are only so many spots for players
in the America's League this is
exemplified by the plethora of talent in
tier 2 bcj FIA Nismo koala Noob scuba
I'm sure if there was room they would be
at the top the idea of a tier 2
inferiority exists because we have made
it exist it is a contract by and in some
ways for the community another thing to
remember is that there's essentially
been a drought of valerant Esports since
August so people are are willing to jump
to conclusions after a single tournament
despite the fact that there's only a
small sample size of matches why when
Sentinels competed in the AFA tournament
recently did some people take that as
the ultimate Supreme 100% accurate
litmus test as to how Sentinels would do
this year because there has been nothing
else to watch of course there has been
game changers but that is a completely
different story We Love Game Changers
though shout out Shopify Challengers
League where mxs and oxygen compete have
been without competition since June 2023
sure they have competed in tournaments
here and there but nothing as
high-profile or recent as this
Invitational it really should come as no
surprise that people are massively
extrapolating from this tournament the
Community professional Talking Heads
like myself and fans alike have been
starved of our esport and when we
finally get a few crumbs it can be hard
not to be carried away and while it has
been wonderful to see some very good
valerant for the first time in a very
long time dear viewer let me caution you
I asked MCE former coach of Cloud9 and
the guard now coach of marville and he
said to me that he agreed with the
scrims on steroids comparison basically
with these tournaments you're wanting to
try out comps or ideas to see if they
have potentially Merit or legs to
continue to to pursue it's good to see
potential holes in your play and to get
a good measurement of where you're at
and what you need to focus on as a team
as a reminder last year's lewick ter
Invitational saw the guard versus TSM in
finals while the guard did win the
Ascension tournament and joined their
North American peers as G2 the same TSM
has since withdrawn from valerant last
offseason saw hun thieves win the Red
Bull home ground tournament without
dropping a match after that hun thieves
did not make a single International
Event last year besides that one that
everyone was invited to by default
lockin so before you put all of your
into one apocalypse basket maybe just
take everything with a grain of salt
maybe like a whole bag of it I also
asked scuba the winner of the most
recent lewick trick Invitational and he
echoed that it is a good place to try
things out and iron out mistakes before
the season starts not as serious as leak
matches during the season because the
ultimate goal for most teams is to
either Make Champions or Ascend out of
Challengers but to my experience
everyone is still trying their best to
win so instead of all doom and gloom hun
thieves is washed pack it up or drop
this person maybe just maybe maybe
reframe your thinking a little bit it's
not all doom and gloom nor is it a sign
of things to come people are just saying
that it's just offseason events I feel
like they're coping hard because we beat
their favorite team but uh to be honest
like these offseason events they hard
people want to win mxs was trying their
ass off and I don't know Cloud9 maybe
they weren't trying as hard cuz they
don't really care about these events uh
at least that's just what it seemed like
but I know 100 thieves was trying 100
thieves is a new roster though so like
obviously they were they were just
playing for experience which is really
good for them and they'll definitely be
way better in the season but if we go
back to like the sael land for instance
uh like G2 they they just had a roster
change so I think a lot of these
offseason events are kind of like just
benchmarks and just like good for like
Land Experience and things like that
because of what I said before is how the
professionals view these tournaments
maybe just maybe you should view it like
that too if you're worried about the
deadlock pick just remember scrims on
steroids just relax grab a tea or
whatever pre-workout makes your heart go
a million miles an hour and just get
ready for the VCT which was literally
just announced to begin on February 16th
so get ready I have a feeling it's going
to be a good
year I cannot wait for the VCT to come
around you have no idea how excited I am
for the VCT to come around go VCT I love
Al Esports I'm so excited can February
16th come here already Yahoo that's my
song
woo